we don't just like send swimsuit ads
into the wild right like we
use facebook to target uh women first of
all women
because that's all the products we sell
who are likely to buy a swimsuit and
that is what
has kept our customer acquisition costs
low it's what has enabled us to scale
as a good business likely to buy a
swimsuit that's not simple that's
probably
what thousands of data points that
facebook
right i mean that's why i love facebook
on one hand facebook existence
is very very good for smaller companies
like you
yeah and i think as a consumer the
smaller companies are amazing
at the same time the more of these
little companies that sprout up
facebook's monopoly gets bigger this
whole push-pull of like
supporting the little guy but also
supporting the giant you know it's
wild could you imagine more extreme
dynamic of this you have
on the one hand this is literally you
know this is literally the most
efficient system ever created to extend
you know small loans and working capital
to mom and pop businesses whether
they're digital or offline or both
um and so it's great and you you know
you literally couldn't you know
replicate it on the other hand
you just have these behemoths that have
access to you know negative cost of
capital money
that are allowed to just you know you
know shove it down everyone's throat all
[Music]
day
welcome this is the first
of a 12 part limited series on yank
speaks
my name is zach grauman i was andrew's
campaign manager on the presidential
campaign of 2020 and now
co-host of this podcast with andrew and
what we're doing now
over the next 12 weeks and this is day
one of this but every thursday we're
going to dive into
the future of a topic and the title of
the series is the future of and today's
topic is called the future of buying
anything buying like what does that
have to do with me and i played this
episode with a few people for a few
people already
and the feedback i was like all right
buying i guess i'm interested in that
i'm not sure do i care about this i
guess i do buy some stuff and then by
the end of this they're like whoa
that was fascinating i just learned crap
ton about where this whole world
is going and that is kind of the goal of
this series i want to talk about stuff
that we know are interesting maybe it's
kind of similar to automation
the way we were like i know that's a
thing then once you dive in you're like
oh my gosh this touches
my life in so many ways so i want to do
three things this episodes folks
one i wanted to dive into the world of
e-commerce today like
how we buy and sell transactions and how
the internet has completely changed that
both on the business side and how we hit
it as customers
two i want to talk about where it's
going i wonder what the cutting edge of
this looks like
for years to come and then lastly
in true injury yang fashion i want to
talk about our humanity how this
actually impacts
people and humans and families so i
brought on two amazing guests the first
guest is a guy named jesse horwitz
and jesse is a co-founder and ceo of a
company called
hubble contacts and has started a bunch
of e-commerce sites you have likely
bought or bought one of jesse's products
at some point
or seen his facebook ads he is a digital
advertising and digital ecommerce master
um and the other guest is this
incredible entrepreneur melanie travis
who's the founder and ceo of a company
called
andy which is a women's swimwear company
and they sell
only online and it's amazing to see how
different that type of business is than
businesses started maybe a decade ago or
even
more recently this conversation is
dynamic it's exciting we dive into a
topic and more importantly i think on a
personal level
one of the things i want to provide to
you as you listen to this
is the ability to learn something
because i think
we've kind of gone away from that a bit
and i think it's really core to what
andrew yang stood
for so when i listened to andrew yang
particularly when i first met him
i was just always learning and he just
knew so much about a specific
like how the economy was working and
what was happening in the 4th industrial
revolution
and so what we wanted to do on this
limited series is find people who are
smart on certain topics
dive in and understand what is going on
how this is going to touch our lives
and ideally go on this learning journey
together but like let's go and dive in
and actually learn something if you're
gonna get on the podcast
you're gonna listen to one put it in
your ears maybe come out a better
smarter person
and so i've i learned a ton from this
conversation in particular
jesse and melanie are they're incredible
they're just fascinating humans and
they're easy to listen to and they know
a lot um
so i'm excited i'm working hard on this
you're going to love it
so sit back and buckle up we're about to
dive into the future of buying
here on yank speaks
[Music]
jesse and melanie welcome to the future
of on yankspeaks
thank you for being here thanks excited
to be here
so melanie let's let's start with you
maybe tell us a little bit about
about andy your company how you guys
work and frankly how you got into this
because i think
entrepreneur story is always fascinating
to me my background real quick is really
in building consumer internet companies
i started my career at a company called
foursquare and then i went to
kickstarter a crowdfunding platform um
and after kickstarter i worked at
barc best known for barkbox a monthly
box of toys and treats for dogs so so
really have spent my whole career in
venture-backed
um consumer internet brands that are all
about building communities online uh
some
e-com others you know checking in to
different restaurants um
but so that's what my background all in
the new york city area
um and i started andy because um first
of all i you know really got to see sort
of how it's done and i got the itch to
do it myself
so definitely wanting to follow a path
that i found to be really exciting and
exhilarating
and then i landed on swim just because
that's a personal fashion point for me
and
a sort of pr consumer problem that i and
many women in my life have
have dealt with i mean shopping for a
swimsuit as a woman is hard
um frankly it sucks i hope i can say
that word yeah
yeah welcoming speaks we kind of don't
have a filter you're fine
um i just wanted to solve swimwear
shopping is really what it came down to
and i felt that i
could figure out how to do that um and
here we are you know
three and a half actually almost four
years later um
and we're well on our way to doing that
we've built quite a
quite a company on on the path to that
you're all online
we're all online we only sell on
andyswim.com no brick and mortar
no affiliate no wholesale just uh just
our own site
so i'm excited you're here because that
i think
is very telling of what is to come or
what can be
jesse you've you've sold a lot of
different things i think one of the
things we've talked about you've also
sold adult
diapers online you've sold which i just
wanted to say
um but like you can sell any of this
stuff so tell us a little about you
how you got into this i was a law school
dropout i was i went from
i interned at bridgewater after my 1l
year at law school
ended up on the investment team for
columbia university's endowment for a
few years
and while i was at columbia kicked the
tires with some friends on a few
different ideas and i had a friend from
bridgewater who was over at harry's
which is the shave subscription in the
city
um and we started doing work on contact
lenses
you know 2015 or so and it was the great
um
it was the great box subscription boom
of
november 2015 to june
um and we were you know we were just
part you know
part part of that illustrious cohort um
so so we lost we started selling
um we raised money in may um
left left the endowments launched in
november um and yeah since then have
gotten
live with all sorts of stuff on the
e-commerce side so
adult diapers which somebody else owns
now sadly because it's a good time for
adult diapers
at home code um
wrote a book called selling naked about
selling stuff so sell that too
um and yeah you know and all sorts of
uh random stuff i want to give me to
this so
in the past like let's call it less than
10 years ago
if you wanted to start a business you
want to particularly one that's selling
a product you needed to
design the product and then frankly buy
it yourself
store it find some sort of inventory
management
usually find a physical location to sell
it and then
in order to get people to straight up
purchase it and open their wallet you
had to do some form of billboard or word
of mouth advertising
um and that model i just talked about is
completely flipped on its head it's gone
um i mean
people can still do it and you feel like
some but like those are the exceptions
that i think prove the rule
walk me through how e-commerce from a
product standpoint works today and
andy maybe the best example like how
where the product is how it's sold like
how that whole situation is flipped on
its head
hearing you describe that i think where
i went to where my head went was
there are parts of that that continue
today but it's it's basically like
dramatically modernizing how that's done
so for how andy does it um
i mean some of what we do is quite
traditional we take what has worked
traditionally for a product business and
then just like layer on all the modern
ways to make it actually work today
so we do design our swimwear for example
that hasn't changed we designed the
silhouettes that we want
um obviously given that we're an ecom
company
uh we are very close with our customer
we don't sell through middleman so we're
always talking to our customer
so all the designs come from a customer
that might be a way that we're
innovating
on the the design of the product in the
past i think historically companies hire
a designer who sits on a pedestal and
says this is what the trend will be and
then they make the thing how do you get
the impact or the feedback from the
customers
like is it just through facebook and
yelp or whatever like review sites you
have or how do you do it a bunch of ways
we send service we say we're thinking of
these silhouettes what's your favorite
um we have in-house customer support
that emails text
chats talks on the phone to our customer
and says what would you like to see
um we run ads on facebook tell us what
you want um so
we ask yeah and there's a lot of
different tools you can ask now and
and you get that back quickly exactly
and we get it back really quickly and we
use slack and you know for internal
communication and we have a slack
channel that's just you know what what
customers are looking for in product and
we just
put it all there and then our product
team will flip through it and say like
these are the things that that we should
make given customer demand
um so it really comes from the customer
we design the stuff um
and then you know we manufacture all
over the world um and
we do i mean we hold we we hold
inventory so that's another piece where
your first model is is what we're doing
today
um we work with three pls which is uh
basically a warehouse the product goes
to the warehouse then we have one on the
west
coast one on the east coast one thing
that does exist today
is you know all sorts of different
inventory financing solutions
so it makes it much more accessible for
anyone you
anyone listening to literally go do this
themselves with inventory financing when
you say that like that means some
instead of me buying all that product
myself
someone would only like help me pay that
back
as the orders come in based on a
percentage of what my cut is like how
does that work
yeah well there's there's really a lot
of different ways it can work um
so some of them they'll just fund your
inventory up front they'll
literally write you a check to cover
whatever you need to buy um
but then you know they obviously are
going to make money on that and
they do risk it by i guess owning a
piece of your inventory to your original
point about how things have changed so
much
a lot of these manufacturers are really
beholden to the
traditional wholesale model and they
want a foot in ecom
they want to be part of the sort of ecom
thing that's happening
and so they're willing to make pretty
interesting deals with an ecom company
in exchange for equity
and that happens to be the model that i
used and so the way that i was able to
do this
is i said you know i want to place these
really big orders i don't have the cash
to pay for the order now
give me something call it like net 90
day terms
which is you know when the swimsuits hit
the warehouse i have 90 days until i
have to actually pay the manufacturer
for those swimsuits
and so that is what allows a young brand
to really grow because you don't have to
pay for the inventory until you've sold
it
um so that's another way that i think
and that's a model that i know that um
jesse's also into and it's just it's a
great way of growing an e-com
um brand some businesses are truly
coming up with new product categories
but
by and large these are you know existing
product categories or even something
like
weighted blankets which is a popular
e-commerce category
um maybe not totally original to
e-commerce but
you know but definitely was popularized
through instagram um but you know still
just blanket manufacturing
and so like i think if you think about
this whole universe um
there you know there's this idea that
like we should be building that you know
building everything from scratch
but really a lot of this is taking a lot
of
infrastructure that already exists
whether that's existing manufacturers or
you've seen a lot of this during covet
existing retailers also independent
retailers you know the nikes of the
world were way ahead on this but
even independent retailers setting up an
ecommerce presence
um but but you know everybody trying to
figure out how to get this direct
distribution channel so
you know so what was sort of the venture
version of this story pitched maybe
five or six years ago uh that you know
we were going to build the whole
universe from scratch just to distribute
it through e-commerce and then create
sort of owned operated
retail for those e-commerce brands and
that was going to be the omni channel
solution for all this
um you know i think has fallen back to a
much more logical place which is
lots of stores that work already lots of
manufacturers that work already
um how you know how do we line up their
needs
you know with this new marketing
distribution channel the exact product
specs may be different but at the end of
the day that's the infrastructure
that's going to deliver those product
specs at the best cost and the best
value for the consumer which is you know
quality adjusted consumers want value um
and it's kind of hard to start from
scratch and arrive at that place
so there's certain businesses that have
existed let's call it weighted blankets
right well there already are a bunch of
people making them
there's already a bunch of distributors
that are probably mainly brick and
mortar maybe some websites where
you can buy a way to blanket at target
or maybe cbs or whatever it is
and you've got what's called disruptors
like yourselves are like hey
weighted blankets like they're actually
pretty customizable or like you can have
a million different
shapes and sizes and delivery times that
if i can hyper target who can buy
them and then buy them and make them
available in real time and only order
exactly what people want
to who wants it and where they are
there's an opportunity to have a better
customer experience and make more money
and have
like a smoother operation and you're
saying every product's different and
ideally if you're building into one that
already is
a relative market it works better yeah i
mean to use andy as an example like you
know
familiar with melanie's manufacturer you
know they they they supply for lots of
you know for lots of different partners
but the kind the kind of product that
they're making for
the other partners looks nothing like
the andy you know looks nothing like the
product for andy
um and so like you're taking all those
raw capabilities of pro you know of good
good product construction um low cost on
the you know
on the manufacturing side all that scale
and you know and you're funneling it to
the needs of the specific
audience in this specific channel that
is cool what's new is
their interest in working with brands
like andy because they've seen this
explosion of ecom and whereas in the
past they may have said oh your scale is
not interesting
you know you're not one of these massive
department stores what they have
realized is that the world is shifting
and actually striking deals with
companies like andy can be
very beneficial and andy has grown
tremendously year over year i mean i
think it has knocked their socks off and
they're so happy that they signed this
deal you know four years ago
um when we were just a tiny little thing
how crazy was it going into these what's
called the manufacturer deal and you're
like hey
i've never sold a bathing suit before
yeah i bet this is your first
company you ran right oh yeah yeah first
time ceo
all that and they're like you're like
and believe in me like out of that
imposter
syndrome is real i can say that i think
it's not
oh my god i mean and i actually went
with jesse to some of these meetings
because he
was introducing me to some of these
major manufacturing players
um and we're going together i think he
was kind of cool as a cucumber like he
always is
jesse just figured i was like oh my how
are they going to take me seriously but
you know like they did they do you have
conviction in your idea and then your
product or what you know conviction and
whatever it is you want
to do and and that's what you put on the
table and someone's going to pick it up
i want to talk to you all about your
most valuable asset
and that is time we always are running
out of it
we never can have enough of it so that's
why we have partnered with stamps.com
because what they do better than most
things particularly when you're mailing
stuff is save
you time so stamps.com brings the
service of the us postal service and ups
right to your computer so you can get
your stamps print them online
and save a trip to the post office
because that is
by definition a hassle so save your time
you can use this 24 7 and get your
stamps at stamps.com from anywhere in
the world
so here's what i want you to do stop
wasting time go in the post office and
go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
yang you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long term commitments or contracts so go
to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in yang that's
stamps.com
promo code yang stamps.com never go to
the post office again
[Music]
you get feedback from your from your
customers in real time
you've got a manufacturer that has the
scale and ideally distribution and
ability to pretty much create anything
and they're doing it they're now doing
it a smaller scale because they're
following the market
how are you finding your customers we
use um facebook and instagram
both paid and organically so organic
would be go to instagram.com
andyswim and you see our stuff we also
run ads um
and and we use a little bit of snapchat
a little bit of tick tock
uh we're on pinterest and we're we're
sort of like following
the what i would call the sort of
cutting edge of digital marketing so
always
next to find that you know the channel
where people are going to
and then and then it's really about the
creative i mean for
you know swim is a visual thing you want
to see what a swimsuit looks like
um probably quite different from contact
lenses in that regards
i can't really see a lens yeah but i
mean we run all sorts of goofies i mean
we run
contact lenses in a bowl of milk um we
run
um you know driver going into contact
lenses
um you know it's one of the things
that's really interesting about it
as melanie said it's you know it's
across a few platforms but this kind of
direct response top of funnel traffic
which is
uh you know old traditional ad
traditional advertisers always like to
say you know
segment between their brand spend and
their you know
and their bottom of funnel spend and
when your marketing budget was just
search and tv that kind of makes sense
because you're running brand stuff on
tv and you're running um you know then
you're buying your keywords on search
you know but targeted paid
you know uh digital you know digital
media kind of serves both
both roles you're getting that um you
know you're you're getting that very
measurable return on the ad dollars
but you're also getting that branded
impression with the consumer
so when you say top of funnel bottom
funnel just for listeners who may not
have phones top of the funnel is like
but like market like your brand the
budweiser frogs
we make it yeah we make it normal and
then bottom of the funnel is like
getting people like you drink beer in
this city you wear bathing suits because
you live in new zealand or
and you're on the beach or whatever and
that's the hyper laser focus am i
getting that right
i mean for us as you know top funnel is
something very lifestyle-y like here are
beautiful
you know bathing suits on a beach in new
zealand oh
this is andy bottom funnel is something
that's designed to convert the person
like
here is the swimsuit this is the cost
this these are the specs
like it's way more conversion oriented
rather than like the budweiser frogs
which are more just like
brand brand awareness and it's
interesting because then you talk to
like
uh you know whatever you talk to the
econ manager for like a
you know a cpg brand like you know
procter gambler colgate or something
like that
they don't accept sort of the dual
purpose that the you know that that the
branded digital spend is serving so
they'll say like oh you know my
you know the generally their budget's
mostly just going to be search
um and you know in a lot of branded
search so like you know if i'm the brand
manager
um for colgate i'll buy you know call
you know colgate toothpaste as a search
term or whatever
um or you know or tied or whatever it is
and then they say like oh you know my
return on
you know my return on digital ads is so
much higher than yours
but like that you know that's being
supported by a multi-billion dollar
uh you know offline offline media
exactly so this is actually kind of the
crux this
i think so many things have changed like
when i grew up i guess i haven't ruled
out this dream when i grew up i was
wanted to be um i wanted to create
commercials i thought this is a fun way
to do it and back in the day
like that was like everything for a
company or a brand or an idea or it's
like
if you get the um the budweiser frogs
wrong
you know you screw that up i was
watching the tiger documentary hbo which
is
mind-blowing um but they made an awesome
incredible nike like
hello world on tiger woods maybe you're
right for me but i'm not
maybe i'm not ready for it but are you
ready for me like this is like
racially charged and in like a really
positive way it was so awesome
um but if you get that wrong
you know that's why nikes were making so
much money and they're putting so much
money out if you get that wrong
that was kind of it like you didn't have
the opportunity to hit the bottom of the
funnel and convert at a higher rate
right um but
now jesse's talking about putting
contact lenses in
in a bowl of milk just to see if people
like it like i'm sure you guys are able
to a b c
d e f like iterate over and over and if
you flop
it costs what 100 bucks 10 bucks
whatever it is right that kind of thing
and if it flops it's not that visible
it's no one sees it yeah just
actually by definition no one saw it um
because it didn't work right um so
melanie have you how have you guys
it's almost like you're building your
brand from the bottom up
right um like how have you guys tried
that it has been things you tried that
sucked and like you just never talked
about like what like oh for sure
yeah i mean that's the other thing about
direct response marketing is you know
we get feedback from customers on what
kind of swimsuits they want to see from
us
but we also get that feedback from the
ads that we run and let's say we do
um we had like a pink striped suit you
know a couple seasons ago
and we'd made it and we ran it on we ran
ads for it on instagram and facebook and
the conversion rate on those ads was
miserable
and so what we found is that um women it
like even though some amount of women
that we had heard from directly wanted
something like this
it wasn't wasn't resonating and so we
cut our buy and we
didn't buy any more of it and um and
that was it so a lot of product
decisions are being made
kind of from the marketing channel which
i think is also new i'm sure in the past
you know you'd you'd put in a big po
you'd invest in whatever the product is
and then like
the marketing team just has to sell it
you know like you're the
brand is committed to it they have to
sell it and we're able to be a lot more
committed we're in like pink stripe
bathing suits like make them work
yeah and now now we can be super nimble
you know you start with a small po
you you test something you know his
purchase order purchase order yeah
um or you don't even i mean frankly you
don't even have to buy the thing to
begin with like you can just have
someone mock up a design
you know photoshop it onto a person put
it either on instagram facebook on your
site with like wait list you know
sign up when we launch it and see if you
get enough email addresses to make it
worthwhile to even buy the product do
you even know
um pet costumes together
wow about that what we were gonna do
or just like just all day all year long
for yours for your
for your everyday pet life like hot dogs
did they sell oh yeah okay no no
i would love i would love us to be the
uh the lords of
pet costumes but it was not meant to be
you know i think in the past you would
have had to do a big
big upfront investment to launch a
business like that we tried it didn't
work closed it on to the next
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by public goods the one stop shop
for sustainable high quality
everyday essentials made from clean
ingredients at an affordable price it's
everything from coffee to toilet paper
to shampoo to pet food public goods
is your new everything store rather than
buying from a bunch of single product
brands
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials essentially
in one place with a beautiful
streamlined aesthetic
and what they do is they search a globe
to find clean healthy eco-friendly
innovative products so i am right now
all about the han soap it smells
beautiful it's like orangy cinnamony
when you have a good hand soap so that
nice feeling
and you know it's coming from a good
place so i am a big fan
we've worked out an exclusive deal just
for yang speaks podcast listeners you're
going to get 15
15 bucks off your first public goods
order with zero minimum no minimum
purchase at all so that's right
they're so confident and we are too
you're going to love their products and
come back again and again that they're
giving you bubble goods literally just
give you 15 bucks
to spend on your first purchase you have
nothing to lose at all so go to
publicgoods.com
yang use the code yang at checkout so
that is
p u b l i c g o o d s dot com
forward slash gang get 15 off your first
order
at public goods check it out
[Music]
how would jesse and i got connected and
one of the things we did
on the 2020 presidential race was we
treated andrew
as much as possible as a e-commerce
product which sounds
cold and heartless but we we didn't have
a big ad budget
right we actually had no budget and it
was funny because i was i would go to
events
and a lot of the events we were doing
were either there's political reporters
there or
donors or fundraisers who are like more
traditional um and they're like you guys
need to be doing more of x they'd be
like you need to be
doing more roundtable events on certain
topics and we would try those we try to
do events we'd sell tickets on them and
no one gave a crap like there were so
many traditional things like uh yeah
everybody says they want that but
no one wants it um and what they did
want was
rallies those weren't great um they
wanted um
like various donation conversions worked
some didn't something but like a lot of
times that we had a progress bar where
people like felt like their donation was
moving the needle on something they
cared if it was just like
donate for this random politician it was
less exciting um so
i guess my point was it it's almost like
you end up building this brand
almost solely on the voices of the
customer
right like is that like you end up with
this product that you know is going to
sell because it's
literally like evolved
out of popular demand and that's what we
felt do you guys feel that when you
when you do this you did a much better
job at it than i ever have but yes uh
that that you know that i think that's
exactly how it works
yeah so we shop cursing was one it was a
fun one we're like all you know when the
end curse is like
you gets a lot more clicks people like
it a lot more so maybe yeah
let's find a balance i think people are
just starting to see
the power of all this i mean you think
about something like amc
and i i will always be one course
international film too i will always be
one course away from a film studies
major
um so you know so i'm personally rooting
hard for movie theaters to recover
but like you know this crazy feedback
loop of uh you know twitter latched on
to amc as a name
um amc actually completed a billion
dollar financing as a result
and now the odds that amc is you know
continues to exist as a go forward um
you know going concern is much higher
than it was previously and so like it's
um you know i there's you know people
always like to talk and
i i came from the investment side i get
it you know the fundamentals of the
situation and
this and that but you know i think
you're seeing those feedback loops here
where actually like it can make its
you know um the digital stuff can sort
of make its own reality
it's not just sort of one one-way
communication of what's going on
so one of my concerns here there's only
a select number of companies
and one of them in particular facebook
that you can actually advertise with and
do this
and they um facebook as the first mover
and realistically that the platform they
created is like
the first the best mover besides you
know my i guess our myspace and a few
others but once once the once one is
built it's very tough to replace it
because it becomes
the fabric of society and how we're all
connected
but like right now in
like political campaigns and causes
cannot use facebook
to advertise and they're toast like they
literally have no
other option to get into the internet of
marketing which is where all marketing
is right now essentially
um so thoughts on
facebook's role here and what that looks
like is that sustainable going forward
have you looked at
found other effective options to sell
your products outside of facebook i know
you mentioned a bunch but doesn't sound
like they were a key player mel yeah
start with you but like what are your
thoughts on facebook's role here
yeah i mean you know where my mind went
while you were speaking is the ios
updates i don't know if that's something
that um you guys have talked about or
jesse's
explain it i haven't talked about the
podcast like the new like iphone updates
iphone apple is rolling out new uh ios
14 a new update to your iphone
and that'll roll out throughout the
course of the year so it's not going to
be like a one and done bam immediate
thing
but in when you update when you get that
notification to update your phone
and you update it usually do it
overnight whatever
when you're done updating there will now
be a pop-up that basically will say
something along the lines of
um do you want to opt-in to allow
you know brands or companies or
advertisers to trace
your activities um that is a default
right now
so if you're if you have an iphone it's
like but unless you go to settings
out not opt-in correct currently right
now
you're you're in it and you have to go
find it buried in settings topped out
the new ios 14 is gonna opt everyone out
and you have to click to opt
in okay now i don't think a lot of
people are gonna click to opt into that
right and that is basically going to or
has the potential to
really destroy or at least severely mess
with
the facebook you know business platform
um
when you can't trace the customers i
mean we don't we don't just like send
swimsuit ads into the wild right like we
use facebook to target uh women first of
all women
because that's all the product we sell
who are likely to buy a swimsuit and
that is what
has kept our customer acquisition costs
low it's what has enabled us to scale
as a good business and if those
acquisition costs go up because suddenly
we're targeting
you i mean like you can buy women
swimsuit if you want but you're less
likely
you said the term likely to buy a
swimsuit
that's not simple that's probably what
thousands of data points
that facebook right i mean that's why i
love facebook
[Music]
you know that credit card the one that
you're looking at and you're always
afraid like oh god don't tell me what my
credit card
balance is like that and you're voting
your debt upstart is something that can
help you pay that off
get you better interest rates and help
you get out of credit card debt and last
year if you know anything about 2020
you never know what life's gonna throw
at you you never know when you need
credit cards it's time to take control
with
upstart so you know exactly what to
expect and if you have multiple credit
cards you can use upstart to start
consolidating them and they make things
simple with one monthly payment
in one place so upstart is the fast and
easy way
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt all online literally half a million
people have done this they use upstart
to get simple fixed
monthly payments and you can too so find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
yang that's upstart.com yang don't
forget to use our url
and let them know that yankspeak sent
you loan amounts can be determined based
on your credit
income certain other information
provided in your loan application
so go to upstart.com
i think the other thing you see
happening at the same time is
you know for a long time we've kind of
had the
top of funnel digital spend to ourselves
because the branded advertise the
traditional branded advertisers have
been content to hang out on tv
and i think you're seeing like you're
seeing the you know
the uh you know both what apple's doing
um california rolling out the sea
the ccpa last year you're seeing those
things which are shifting you know the
ability to target ads and at the same
time you're seeing
tv inventory really start to crater to
the point where i like i'd be like
um super bowl weekend super bowl weekend
is usually not a big deal for e-commerce
advertisers like you
there's periods in the year where you're
where ad rates spike and you're sort of
you know kicked out you know
it's it's harder to spend efficiently in
the auction and then there's periods
where there aren't this was the first
year like super bowl weekend was awful
uh you know you could you could just
feel a lot of you know sort of more
traditional brand advertisers who are
used to stepping up their marketing
spend around the super bowl
um sort of flat you know flex into the
facebook auction they went they put
their money in digital
yeah exactly they have to because what
they've been doing for years is they've
just been bidding up
that you know they've been burying their
heads in the sand and bidding up the
value of the tv
impressions um and you know and just not
putting much into digital
um and so you can see these two you know
honestly not in ways that are great for
me
but like you could see these two things
come together which is if on the one
hand fit you know
a lot of the targeting capabilities of
you know facebook and other platforms
are
restricted and on the other hand um
the offline inventory is finally just
melting down to the point that like
you know that traditional advertisers
are forced with their noses held to
spend more on digital
um you know that that these things just
you know become
um sort of traditional brand marketing
platforms which you know has
has all the privacy benefits that you
know that you you know that you'd
imagine but also
but have the you know the downside of
like less relevant ad impressions for
consumers so you know you just
seen tight ads the way that tv's offline
inventory i'm assuming
is cable tv ads or broadcasts ads or
billboards that sort of thing and not so
online inventory would be
what we're talking about um like
facebook google that sort of thing so
on one hand facebook existence is very
very good
for smaller companies like you
yeah and i think as a consumer the
smaller companies are amazing
because i know the brand i feel a brand
like i've we've used brands
um there's one called outer known that's
actually like a sponsor here for our
podcast that we love like there's a
bunch i i love these brands
um there's a company called grayson i
love i think they make great
pullovers and they they're like they
were an e-commerce company and like
when like when you i got you actually
zero point do the surveys and tell them
like hey these pants are awesome they
like stretch a little bit funny
and the next round of pants like we're
better and like sweet
this is a good thing right and there's
people like you starting companies
creating jobs incredible yes we created
a lot of jobs in covid i'm sure ecom
companies created
way more than sort of wholesale historic
businesses
we're higher we're on a hiring spree yes
so facebook enables that
right um at the same time
the more of these little companies that
sprout up
facebook's monopoly gets bigger which is
probably a net
negative so like what what are your
thoughts on that that's like so it's
like
i think that's the big push and pulling
i think you're seeing it
like it's clear on the ad side i think
that the the one that's that people will
start paying attention to is the payment
side as well because
everybody you know everybody people get
how facebook and google
and you know to a lesser extent amazon
make money
the the thing that people miss is if
you're not those three companies and
your
business and your pitch to investors is
that you're making money around
e-commerce it's on payments so
whether that's shopify or stripe or
um paypal or square or whoever it is all
these players are
are saying that they're going to make
money on payments like big investors
aren't looking at
andy and saying this is my go-to they're
looking at a payment company that's
helping the andes
and the hubble's of the world make money
is that what you're saying
you can either be an ad platform for
brands or you can be a capital provider
for brands and like
most people you know and most of the
entities in the you know 50 billion plus
um you know weight class um in this
space or one or the other
um and the payment side gets you know if
you like what does
payments really mean payments really
means like lending um you know
you you're integrating you're providing
a credit card processor the way you
really make money off of that is you're
getting a cup you're getting the small
businesses or you know an independent
brands
um you know transaction data and then
you're extending them loans
um so like this whole push-pull of like
supporting the little guy but also
supporting the giant
you know it's wild could you imagine
more extreme dynamic of this you have
on the one hand this is literally you
know this is literally the most
efficient system ever created to extend
you know small loans and working capital
to mom and pop businesses whether
they're
digital or offline or both um and so
it's great and
you know you literally couldn't you know
replicate it on the other hand you just
have these behemoths that have access to
you know
negative cost of capital money that are
allowed to just you know
you know shove it down everyone's throat
all day um so
you know so yes i think these these
exact kind of you know put
push and pull of the you know the
platform and everyone else
um that's exactly that's exactly the
awkward tension i feel like it's amelia
i'm so curious your thoughts i just feel
like it's a good
thing until facebook and apple get in a
turf war and then who's gonna pay the
price
andy i think right like what what do you
think i mean it's funny because that you
know we're talking about
the future like this the theme here is
the future of buying the or the future
of shopping and
and i mean it well first of all it's
just so opaque but second of all like
i think in a lot of ways there's going
to be a reversion
i mean maybe this is an unpopular
opinion but a reversion back to
at least some something that what you
know i feel basically where i come out
on all of this is that i feel very
thankful that andy started when it did i
think it's becoming a lot harder
to start a small business these days for
all the reasons we've just described
um and that's unfortunate i think it
should be going the other way
which you know there should be more
small businesses because like you said
they're great i love supporting small
businesses i love that they pay
attention to me i love the value like
everything we've talked about
um but i think it's really hard today um
i mean in some ways the barrier to entry
is lower than ever
there is capital going around you can i
mean i feel like i can email every day
with people asking to give andy money
great but like you have to spend it
efficiently you have to build a good
business you know and i think that
that's the part that's becoming
it's just tricky
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by liquid iv
the reality is this energy multiplier is
a game changer so i take this stuff
pretty frequently sometimes i take it
when i'm a little hungover and i'll see
you sometimes i take it just in the
morning give me a pick me up it's got a
little caffeine in it but it's got
energy
it's got three times the amount of
hydration you get from a glass of water
it is a very quick and easy open the
packet dump it in water mix it up and
drink it
way to improve your energy in the
morning or frankly at any time
half americans right now say they
struggle with daily fatigue i bet that
number's higher
i am one of those this is an awesome way
to do it and plus
frankly the taste on this thing is
exceptional i have an apple pie one that
i love i love the lemon lime there's a
whole bunch you can get
you can grab your energy liquid iv in
bulk nationwide
at costco or you can get 25 off when you
go to liquidive.com
use the code yang at checkout that's 25
off
anything you order when you use the
promo code yang ying at liquidiv.com
so start fueling your adventures today
get that fatigue gone
get the energy up liquid iv.com promo
code
yang
i'm curious what like policy solutions
are and the one i was thinking was like
look
what we did in the
the big trust breakups or the big
monopoly breakups where it's your your
trains your rockefellers your
vanderbilts where they
are owning things that eventually become
a form of a public good
um where everybody needs a train and
whoever took all the risk on to build
that is just gonna own it and they can
they can abuse that power so they get
rich because
it takes a lot of heart and strength and
expertise and risk and all that stuff to
you know you you create you still you
have your rich families and people
and employees that took that risk on but
eventually you start to have to
distribute the gains because you're
hurting people and i wonder if facebook
ends up having
the same thing where they own all the
data
as of now there's no platform where
others are going to be sharing that much
data
at the same point there's probably
google's one in apple's one but
eventually the government has to say
look we need to start brokering this
information
out for the mom and pops of the world
you can still get a cup but you will not
be printing money hand over fists like
you used to because
the people here now are now a generation
removed so they didn't take the risk
they don't deserve it
um you're just you're you built the note
around your business
and it's time for the government to kind
of just yeah i don't like the level the
playing field thing but the generally
make this
keep the good and not um and not make it
exploitative i don't know what you guys
think of that
i i mean it's look i look i i selfishly
i you know i i love anything that you
know that supports the
little guy against the platforms like
you know you know trying to wear my
outside hat i think like
i always have a lot of trouble arguing
against things that are good for the
consumer and so if you think like
broadly like what is the net impact of
these large internet
platforms um they you know they create
they create conditions of perfect
information and perfect
competition and infinite substitution
and
uh you know first you know you know
microeconomics 101
when those are the conditions of you
know the market you're in
you're you're you know your profits are
going to be zero um and so
you know so so i have trouble you know
i've
proposed that kind of you know try to
step in and you know and hurt the
consumer by relaxing those constraints
that you know i have trouble with i do
think and it you know
look i mean we're playing it out slowly
over time i think it's funny what you
know when you have these like big
anti-trust conversations it's like okay
20 years ago or whatever facebook didn't
exist 20 years ago but
four years ago everybody loved google
and google was good now google's evil
same freaking people um and so like i
think it's totally reasonable to say
like
20 years ago this was an infant industry
we put a bunch of rules in place to
support it as an infant industry
now it's a cash cow what do you do as a
society you milk your cash cows
and so i think there's like a you know
there's a more gradual sort of
renegotiating the deal
um and i think it could happen in a less
broad way because i don't like
think about how awful covet would you
know it it feels like
oh you know not much harm to hurt these
big players but like
if you know if amazon were meaningfully
incapacitated if some you know some of
the media platforms were media
incapacitated like this whole lockdown
would not have been possible um to the
extent that we you know managed it at
all
and so i i think it's i think it's
tougher because you have you have to do
it gradually because it's it's all based
on
um trying to figure out what level of
you know
what level of profits and revenue these
businesses really need to continue to
operate you know to operate at sort of
peak level
um and so you know they should you know
whatever it's like any
it's like any negotiation you gradually
hack away at that
and yeah and i and the government hasn't
does not have a good track record of
doing the things i just mentioned so it
was
yeah like in terms of trying to get in
there and help distribute the gains here
yeah but each year you chip away a
little bit more and i think you know the
thing that's unfortunate a lot of the
time that you chip away
and you chip away in the game you know
and and the things you chip away go
you know go to a you know go to a
relatively insulated group around the
government
um that you know that you know that gets
it in the form of new you know new rents
expensive regulations to manage and it
would be
a lot nicer if we figured out this time
you know how to take those
you know those excess profits and you
know get them in
actual constituents hands your point
that this stuff that they are and we've
kind of talked about they are really
helping
consumers and small businesses like
objectively not the
not a talking pr point like very real um
mel i don't know what you think melanie
if it was like a way is there is there
in your mind is there something whether
it's regulation or a rule or something
where
um a government influence um that could
help
like this impending whatever it is turf
war between these companies that would
hurt you what do you think
i i mean i i really do i i'm su
basically i've been
like i'm super interested in this and um
feeling very engaged
in the conversation feeling like oh my
god this is something i should really
pay attention to because it will
seriously impact me and my business and
that i'm woefully under qualified to
weigh in on um
so my answer is that i i don't know but
i would want to
get into that no i mean look you're and
you're trying to
keep your company afloat too right like
you to pick your head up andrew talks
about this all the time even on facebook
like facebook's just trying to
make that company work and this stuff's
hard and it's complicated we've had very
smart people on this podcast
um talking about what to do here and
even the best experts in the world
disagree
for e-commerce in general for human
beings buying products
what does the future look like on the
consumer end let's assume things kind of
stay as
is or we continue on the relative path
we're on
is it i'm assuming that the data just
gets better and better
and the technology accessibility gets
better and better at some point i can
buy whatever i want i know exactly what
it is
instantly and you as the company know
exactly where i
am as the fulfiller of that transaction
like where do you see the
where do you see this going from the
consumer standpoint like how is andy
selling more bathing suits
20 years from now i don't know yeah i
mean it's something i spend a lot of
time thinking about
um this is not the most innovative
answer and so i feel
badly about that given the topic of the
podcast but you know when i think about
how to keep doing that you know we
talked a little bit about channel
expansion but
there's there's a whole wide world out
there and we're just in the united
states in australia of course because
counter seasonal um but you know
around these conversations around
facebook and ios and what's happening
um you know i'm meeting a lot with my
marketing team and one of our solutions
is like
let's start selling in the eu let's
start selling in asia let's see what it
would take to enter the chinese market
because you need to diversify in order
to
well you know as a baseline you need to
diversify and if you want to get to you
know selling 200 million swimsuits or
whatever number in the next
few years um you know i mean the u.s is
a huge country
with a huge market um
but as these things are are happening
and all these changes are happening
it's it's you start to cast your eye you
know
across the pond and and see what you can
do over there too
too not not not in replace of but no of
course also
and you have and there's facebook in
those markets but there's also
10 cents there's wechat i mean this i
mean look we talked to a lot of
um individuals in the asian american
community on wechat here they're u.s
citizens
um they use that for everything in china
um
let me talk about knowing what you're
doing with your talk about knowing who
your
your customer is and wechat knows a lot
about or yeah they know a lot about you
um
but yeah maybe that's a good way to put
it is like the more this becomes more
global the competition heats up right
where it's not just facebook as the only
player
um it's probably the us and china
butting heads but you know these
um other markets using different
platforms um
different data different way to target
people i'm hoping that the next 20 years
of commerce are a little more boring
than the last 20 years and that like
a lot of ways it start you know this
whole and maybe this will just be
continue to be the paradigm but you know
the paradigm of like ventures like
you know information technology
investing um and like you know i think
if you were sitting around in detroit
and you had venture as the you know you
know automotive investing
and like you know it would look really
good in 1890 1900
1910 1920 and then like you'd hit your
1935 vintage
and uh ford and gm were created already
um
and it would look real rough from there
uh like this this is start you know
which doesn't mean
like e-commerce will you know whatever
e-commerce will probably continue to
gain share that story is not necessarily
played out but a lot of this starts to
feel like
a more mature industry and that you have
um you know and look i think this is a
lot of the anti-trust tension
um consumers feeling less product
improvement in the services that they're
using and that those are more mature
products
um the companies involved in those
businesses you know trying to maximize
profit over
you know over revenue growth because you
know they're not quite as much in that
like hype you know
hyper growth mode anymore um and and i
think um
i mean i think there's a lot that's
goofy about you know something like
uh bitcoin soaring up above 40 and you
know tesla an 800 billion dollar company
but i think like
you know but uh i think one of the
things in there is like people trying to
you know people hoping that like um
you know if it rotates what what
industry is sort of
um you know the focus and if you went
back 15 or 20 years ago everybody was
excited about bricks and emerging
markets and then the last 10 years have
been
um you know digital and you know in the
90s it was big box and you know and
walmart and
um you know it like every you know an
industry just doesn't get an infinite
day in the sun and i
i think it'd be um i think there's been
a lot of gains from sort of
you know better information management
um but it you know be
i but i for one would be excited to see
you know the next day you know
uh you know something you know energy be
the you know be the really exciting
thing in the next decade life sciences
be the really exciting thing in the next
decade that like
um you know that that like um continued
improvement in how we buy a bundle of
goods that on you know that hasn't
terribly changed very much year to year
for like
decades now um isn't th you know it
isn't like the great marvel of our time
that that is a good way to kind of wrap
this where it's
let's hope for all of us that the
innovations are not coming in e-commerce
because i think we can all agree
it's pretty it's very easy to buy
products now we got that we're
we're not it's not perfect but it's damn
good and
there are a lot of things that are
nowhere near perfect and nowhere near
damn good
let's call it um biotech and
like automotives or you've got a list a
lot of things that make society and the
planet a lot better than
optimizing how fast we buy swimsuits no
offense to
how awesome andy is and how great the
swimsuit is um i can't vouch from
personal experience but
um my sister has said she loves your
product so
great um she's probably your target demo
i think she's 20 she's in her mid-20s so
perfect six i believe anyway i'm she's
going to kill me she's listening to
somebody you don't know how old i am
she's 26 okay
coming up on her upcoming birthday
anyway guys um
i am just so grateful for your time um i
know you're both
literally running people are relying on
on you to lead their company so for you
take an hour
to listen and and and teach me and
hopefully our audience thank you thank
you
um best of luck um on everything you're
doing
and uh i'm gonna what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna check back with both of you in
10 years exactly
and see um how well this did the test of
time if that works for you
i think that's perfect all right cool
[Music]
you